foreign
[Music]
I'd really like to welcome our first
keynote speakers Minaj Randal and Julia
Lowndes
who are going to be talking about quarto
and they're they're literally like no
two better people suited to give this
talk
is my colleague at rstudio she's also my
co-author of alpha data science she is
the professor of the practice at Duke
and just a fantastic educator and I
deeply appreciate her empathy with new
eye users
also whenever I correctly type Mina's
full name including the little dangly
sadilla on the C on the sea I like give
myself a self high five
uh Julie Lowndes is a PhD PhD in Marine
Biology and Squids she also started
openscapes in 2018 supported by Mozilla
uh I Julia is like one of the people I
just love to hang out with at our studio
conf and I whenever I see her because
she is just so passionate about
educating people about the power of R
and whenever I get to hang out with her
I just feel rejuvenated and excited
about the work that I do unfortunately
uh Julie and Mina will not be taking
answering questions today but if you do
ask questions on the slido they will
read them and they will pass them on to
the quarto team
but they will not be taking questions
today so please join me in welcoming
Julie and minae
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so much Hadley and thanks so much
to all of you we are so excited to be
here
Mina and I have been using quarto for
over a year now Mina has been teaching
with it and has been contributing to the
development of it and my teams with
openscapes were the first external
testers of quarto and as we've used it
over the past year we have grown to love
it so much and we are excited to welcome
you to quarto
but also we know you have questions we
did too
what is quarto why is quarto and how
does it interoperate with our markdown
and your other existing workflows
well
Corto unifies and extends the r markdown
ecosystem
it unifies it for people who love our
markdown so that little points of
friction are reduced as you make
websites and books and slides all of
those will now have a common approach
and it extends it for people who do not
yet know are marked down as a friendly
way to work reproducibly and publish
documents that combine text and code and
output in the same place
so quarto is a new open source
scientific and Technical publishing
system
and the goal is to make the process of
creating and collaborating dramatically
better
so it handles inputs in multiple
languages and outputs in multiple
formats all going through the same
quarto machinery
so in our talk today we'll introduce you
to quarto through stories and demos
first Mina will focus on how Corto
unifies the our markdown ecosystem
through stories of sharing and teaching
and then all focus on how quarto extends
the our markdown Ecto system through
collaborating and reimagining
so we are so excited to get started so
let's kick it off with you Mina to talk
about sharing with quarto
thanks Julie I'm so excited to have the
opportunity to talk to you about Corto
which I've been living and breathing
over the last year
so I work at the intersection of
Education research and development the
word educator might make you think that
I am in front of crowds like this maybe
we might smaller 24 7 lecturing at them
but actually I spend a lot of my time in
front of my computer
creating and authoring artifacts that I
share with the world for the purpose of
teaching and I often think I everything
I create I share openly with an open
license that allows for use reuse and
adaptation
um I often think web first for wider
reach but I also still live in the
confines of Academia and traditional
publishing which means that I still have
to make a lot of PDFs therefore an
authoring system that allows me to
achieve multiple outputs from the same
uh inputs the same source code that
brings code and prose together is not
only essential for me but it's um it's
actually basically what I need to carry
on my existence and for the last decade
that has been marked down our markdown
for me in fact I remember very vividly
when JJ and UA gave a talk at usar 2012
the first to use our I attended on
knitter
um so I'll kind of go back to that time
I when I attended that conference I
don't think I would have identified
myself as an R person in fact I'm pretty
sure we went to that conference because
we were going to Bonnaroo already and it
was there and I thought why not this was
the summer of my first year of teaching
at Duke
um I was very dedicated to open science
I had already been working on an open
source textbook but this idea of
um kind of wider reach and open science
but also doing Computing I had not
really put the pieces together and one
of the reasons why I had not put those
pieces together is that I didn't have a
good workflow to bring them together if
you know me you know that I'm a prolific
sharer and
um and I like things to look pretty as
well not just be functional and pretty
and I really did not have a good
workflow for being able to achieve that
but I started listening to this keynote
on Knitter and it must have been no more
than three slides into it that I just
actually pulled out my laptop and
started converting my teaching materials
to use it because this idea that I can
bring narrative and then code together
and have it just be like syntax
highlighted and look organized and be
ready to be published on the web was
just such a dream come true for me and
by the end of that keynote I was already
brainstorming ways of not just me using
it but thinking about how can I teach
this to my intro students
so I am going to call this keynote a
success if some of you have already
tuned me out
uh brought took out your laptops and
have gone to corta.org to start playing
with it
um but I do hope that you will continue
to listen with one ear and taking these
beautiful illustrations by Alison Horst
and for those of you who want a kind of
a more laid back morning you can go to
this link
mina.corto.pub hello Corto sit back and
I will advance the slides for you
so Julie mentioned that
um uh about unifying the our markdown
ecosystem so let's dig into that a
little bit more here are some of the
package our packages from the our
markdown ecosystem that you've come to
love and rely on over the years each
package addresses a different need and
solves a different problem you might be
creating websites or writing blogs with
blog down or distill writing books with
book down writing journal articles with
articles package
um quarto unifies the functionality of
these packages on the technical side
building On pandok and On The Human Side
building on over a decade of experience
developing maintaining and tweaking
these packages as well as Community
feedback and the uh Community the
extension package is developed by the
community
and such a unification process presents
a really nice opportunity to identify
and address gaps in functionality and
inefficiencies in user experience and
developing Corto has been no different
so some highlights of these improvements
that are near and dear to my heart are a
consistent implementation of attractive
and handy features across outputs so
tabs heads code folding syntax
highlighting imagine these things just
working out of the box regardless of
what you're producing
also more accessible defaults as well as
better support for creating accessible
documents
guard rails that are particularly
helpful for new Learners things like
yaml completion and informative syntax
errors and perhaps excitingly for those
of you who are not coming to this from
the r markdown ecosystem support for
other languages like python Julia
observable via the Jupiter engine for
executable code chunks
so by now I'm assuming you've already
started playing with Corto or you're
just waiting for me to do that so let's
dive in and take a look at what all the
court of us is about
so here I have something that might look
familiar and our markdown document
try this one more time
and our markdown document
that has some yaml on top some text and
some code
many of you have seen this before let's
knit this document it's a very very
simple analysis using the polymer
Penguins data set that has a nice
visualization at the bottom
so what I'm going to do first is switch
over to the visual editor I personally
really like writing in the visual editor
it allows you to do things like you can
bold things and italicize things without
having to write markdown code and Julie
will do a demo of the visual editor a
bit more later but I'd like to show that
whether you're using the visual or the
source editor with our markdown the
output looks exactly the same so it's
just about your personal preference
about authoring on the input side
but what we're going to do next is
actually change things up let's close up
that file and what I'm going to do is
just rename that rmd to be a qmd and not
touch anything else
the little logo changes I open it up and
what I have is a render button instead
of a knit button and I can see that the
document just works so Corto is able to
render our markdown documents the output
looks a little bit different slightly
different styling
um but we haven't changed anything else
we're going to change the yaml now to
include the format field instead of
output which is how we Define different
format types I'm going to click on
render and save so that I don't have to
click render every time I make changes
so again this is basically our starting
place with quarto I can do different
output formats so let's create a PDF
one of the things I really like about
creating PDFs with Corto as a person who
doesn't like creating PDFs is that the
PDF appears in the viewer as opposed to
in a pop-up window but let's go back to
HTML and take a look at some of these
chunk options so with quarto we're using
the hash pipe for defining our chunk
options which I think helps with
readability a lot and we have really
nice uh completion for yaml so if I
can't figure out what was that chunk
option for hiding my chunks oh Eco how
would I Define my the values true or
false I can rely on the kind of the yaml
completion to do that
and now on the output we don't have that
code chunk appearing anymore
I can also set Global chunks and maybe
like me this is one of your most Googled
things how do I set Global chunks and
Knitter I can actually just do that now
in the yaml through the execute field so
I can turn off the display of code
chunks for the entire document very
explicitly at the top
and now they're all gone
um well we've been working with an HTML
document which is uh going to produce
web ready output let's take a look at
one more thing
um one of the reasons why I like these
uh chunk options as hash pipes is when
you have really long chunk options say
if I want to insert this lengthy text
for as alternative text for the plot
that I am producing
um it it stays very kind of legible and
obviously the alternative text is not
going to be visible in the output but if
I was to inspect that element I can see
that text is in the HTML source code so
that is still accessible to screen
readers making these things easier is
going to make more folks write
alternative text I think for the
visualizations that they're producing
let's make a presentation
um I don't need to touch the rest of my
code I am just going to change my yaml
header to format reveal.js and create a
reveal.js presentation my title page is
a basically whatever was in the yaml of
my document and you can see that each of
the section headers are now new slides I
have that really squished plot because
the reveal.js tries to help me by making
my plots take just as much space as
there is but I can easily insert another
header a second level header to just
move that content to the next slide
and to me being able to do this without
touching the rest of the content is
really really satisfying
all right so let's uh go back to HTML
and next what we're going to do is
attempt to make a website in less than
10 minutes
so I have a single HTML document here
I'm going to create one more document so
we're basically expanding from a single
document to Bringing multiple documents
together
um in um in a quarto project I'm going
to keep this document very simple
intentionally no Computing in there
we're just going to put a little bit of
text so I've titled my document welcome
and maybe let's add some plain text like
this is the demo site for the talk
next to bring them together I'm going to
create a yaml file a quarto.yaml file
and I am going to write yaml on the Fly
and I can do that relying on the tab
completion again so uh we're creating a
quarto project there are various types
of quarto projects you can create the
type where I'm going to select here is
website
and then I am going to Define how I want
to lay out my website let's give it a
title I'll call it quarto and I'm going
to create a navigation bar and on the
left side of the navigation bar I'm
going to link to the two documents I
have the index.qmd I just created and
the hello.qmd that I had renamed from
that original R markdown file
the next thing I'm going to do is I like
to stay in the arcidio IDE but I want my
build tab to be able to get my website
going so I'm just going to restart my
project my rstudio project and I have a
build tab that gives me the option to
render or preview a website let's render
the website and see what that looks like
and there we go we have a website with
multiple pages in it that we have very
clearly written out in this simple and
expressive yaml file to me this is
incredibly encouraging
move
[Applause]
next what I'm going to do is I'm going
to start setting things up for Julie so
and also try to be kind to myself I have
lots of computation in that hello.qmd
let's assume and I don't want this to
constantly keep running every time I
update things so I'm going to set the
freeze feature to True which says only
rerun the computation when I explicitly
ask you to do so in that document
otherwise as I change other things don't
rerun the computation you can see that
when I set this I get this freeze folder
where the results of my computation is
stored and I can set freeze to be other
values like automatic where it would
only update if you actually touch that
file I'm going to set it equal to true
so that let's see if Julie can later
recreate this website in a non-art
environment
so I have a website I have stored my
computations I have multiple Pages what
next
yeah we should be able to publish it
um
all right well we could with one command
um corto.publish sorry quarto publish in
the terminal actually published this to
Corto Pub so if you do want to see the
published website I'm not sure why that
video is hanging but if you do want to
see the published website you could go
to mina.corto.pub
slash hello dash quarto dash demo and
the website is there the two pages that
we created and we're able to do that
without you know setting up things like
actions to run our code and whatnot with
one line from the terminal
all right so what did we see here
um now that you've all had a chance to
kind of see Corto in action you might be
wondering how how are our markdown and
Corto different especially because we
were able to just get things going by
renaming that file the main difference
is that with our markdown it is the r
package our markdown that does the heavy
lifting of what needs to happen to go
from the rmd file to your output and
that's something we as our users are
very accustomed to you want to solve a
problem install that packages the pro
the package that solves the problem you
want to solve with Corto on the other
hand it's the quarto command line
interface so not in our package but a
command line interface something like
git for example that's actually doing
the heavy lifting of taking your input
file
running your executable code chants
through either Knitter or Jupiter
creating a plain text markdown file that
then uses pandoc to get to the output of
your choice
so this is technically pretty impressive
but I'm going to be very honest with you
um it's not exactly what sparked my
interest about Corto what did spark my
interest about Corto was how easy it
makes it to move between
um various formats so as an educator the
things that are of utmost importance to
me is that the artifacts I create are
reproducible and that there's an ease of
transition between various output
formats at the risk of sounding like a
broken record I do actually have to
relay the same information to my
students in slides as uh kind of lecture
notes in a homework assignment posted on
the course website so oftentimes I'm
moving the same content around these
different formats
and over the last year of doing this
with Corto I felt like I finally found
the tool that allows me to do this
easily without fussing around with uh my
code and the content part of my document
but just changing a couple things in the
ammo for example if I want a lesson kind
of a single document as lecture notes or
something I can say format HTML I can
easily change that to reveal.js without
touching anything else in my document
and I have a slide deck I can simply
call that file in a quarto yaml file to
create a website
and you can see that
um the all I needed to change is just
the Seattle
um I didn't have to remove slide breaks
I didn't have to re-level headers uh
that does save me some time and that
time can go to actually focus on the
content that I'm developing and that I
find extremely liberating
But ultimately for the um kind of easily
while easily creating uh documents uh in
multiple formats is nice for the sharing
story to be complete the tool needs to
support easily sharing things as well so
something like that quarto publish
command that you can run in the terminal
and I'm sure soon a button in the rcdo
IDE I think that tooling that makes it
easy to share what you do with the world
on the web is incredibly useful and it's
not just useful to you but to the world
as it facilitates open sharing of
knowledge for Learning and reuse
I've been talking about me and my work
so far but I like many of you don't
operate in a silo disconnected from
others
much of my work and much of Julie's work
is collaborative so over to you Julie
for collaborating with Corto
thanks Mina
I have gained so much from the open
sharing and the web first approach from
the r community and it has so informed
the way that I collaborate and the way
that I work
so I work at the intersection of
actionable environmental science open
science and data science and what I
absolutely love doing is mentoring
teaching and empowering communities
Having learned from so many of you like
I said and I wanted to pay this forward
and welcome more folks to this
experience that I've had with the r and
Mozilla communities in particular so
I've made this my job through openscapes
openscapes is an approach and a movement
that I launched in 2018 and have built
together with my partner Aaron Robinson
our Flagship activity is mentoring
research teams in open science we think
of open science as a beautiful landscape
full of Open Source software data and
communities and many paths forward
and we help people move from the sad
lonely animals in the foreground on the
bottom left and towards this landscape
so that they can explore this and
navigate this safely with their teams
and our role is to welcome Folks at the
trailhead and help them establish what
that Trailhead even looks like who's
there who is part of the team how can we
think about who can be included and
start this journey together with limited
trampling and frustration
so we work with professional research
groups in government Academia and
non-profits and we help these teams
modernize their workflows and shift
their culture with their teams and
within their organizations through open
source software and open source
practices
Adian Rios from NOAA Fisheries has been
part of openscapes and she describes
this in this way
she says as Fisheries scientists we know
that we're when we're in rough Seas it's
important to keep the fish of the okay
the fish to float it's also important to
keep the ship afloat and to get out of
the storm
she says openscapes helps teams steer
out of the storm of email chains with 37
versions of the same spreadsheet and
into the calmer Waters of open science
and meaningful collaboration using tools
like our
so I think that I have the best job I
get to Mentor and collaborate with teams
like audience who are doing really
critical and hard work around
environment and climate and I get to
help them do it a little better by
connecting them to the open source tools
and Community Resources that we all
produce
and it really Blends working with these
teams really Blends for me the role of
mentoring and collaborating because I
learned so much along the way
and this is definitely true with our
story with NASA
with NASA you probably think about outer
space but they collect an unbelievable
amount of data about Earth
and researchers used Earth data in many
ways including how to understand impacts
of the heat waves and the wildfires that
we're increasingly seeing through the
Summers due to climate change
these data are freely available from 12
different data centers across NASA but
researchers have to download these data
locally from each of these data centers
to analyze it locally and this puts a
huge burden on the researchers
so now following many years of
preparation these data are migrating to
the cloud through AWS and others and
NASA data centers will be supporting
researchers who will be migrating their
analytical workflows to the cloud too
so my partner Aaron had 10 years of
experience working with the NASA Earth
data community and she brought NASA and
openscapes together in a three-year
project that we lead together
and our focus is on developing first and
foremost a mentor Community across those
those 12 data centers so that they can
co-create and teach common tutorials for
these researchers using NASA Earth data
so let me just stop here and say that
this is a big project and it is awesome
but it was also incredibly intimidating
to me
I do not know the NASA Community this is
an organization I've looked up to my
whole life
I'm not familiar with these types of
huge spatial data that they're working
with the type of research questions or
scientists are asking and modeling
not to mention Cloud infrastructure
which is a whole new era
but an additional thing that was
particularly intimidating to me as an R
person is that many earth scientists use
python
and they are developing tutorials
primarily in Jupiter notebooks and my
role in leading NASA openscapes was not
to Learn Python from the ground up but I
needed to be able to collaborate and
interoperate and support python users
so something really powerful though is
that I brought almost a decade of
experience and confidence using our
markdown and I've been able to
you've probably heard me talk about this
because I talk about it a lot I feel
like it's a superpower
and quarto let me bring this superpower
to python
Corto is emerging right when we needed
it and I asked JJ if we could use quarto
for NASA openscapes it was really early
in its development and this became a
really exciting collaboration between
the quarto development team and the NASA
mentors this was a really generous and
gracious
group of people together as we were
learning how to collaborate together and
build tutorials and try new software and
we were able to through our questions
and use influence some of the design
features particularly the freeze feature
and how it operates with Jupiter
notebooks
so this is the first quarto site we
developed for our first teaching event
last fall
this is where we really found traction
as a mentor community
and we were able to make this beautiful
collection of tutorials that was first
of all helpful for our own development
as we were learning to collaborate with
each other because we could see which
tutorials were there already and where
the gaps were but it was also a very
friendly contained place for our
Learners to navigate through these
resources
and importantly cuarto was also
something that we were all able to learn
together
and that turned out to be really
important because it turned out I wasn't
the only person who was intimidated by
all these moving pieces on all these new
pieces of software and how to
collaborate together learning Corto
together opened the door for us to talk
more about our workflows and develop
better systems for collaborating and
really take this to the next level
and from all of our investment and
workflows we were then able to rapidly
create additional resources for the
other teaching workshops that we were
leading that were designed to meet those
Learners where they were and
interoperate between the materials we
developed
so there's two things to highlight here
the first is that quarto enables
collaborating across coding languages
this is one peak of a way to think about
this this is a simplified view of one of
our yaml files where you can see we've
got multiple file types here these are
mostly we've mostly focused on IPI and B
Jupiter notebook files in our primary
development so far but as we've worked
more and more with the NASA research
Community we've discovered or that's not
the right word we've found that um
there is a substantial art community
using NASA Earth data cloud and it's
really exciting that the workflow we've
invested in and have developed together
we can use to support our users as well
the second is that quarto enables
contributing from our current tools
so some of our team mainly me and Aaron
used our studio primarily some use juper
lab vs code some directly some edit
directly in GitHub through the editor
and this was really important that we
were all able to use our own tools
because with all these moving pieces we
were able to inter integrate that
workflow into the comfort of our own
tools
so let me show you what quarto looks
like in Jupiter notebooks
so this is a Jupiter notebook and it's
actually running in our Jupiter Hub you
can see we're going to interoperate with
cartoon the terminal here on the right
and we've got all the files that Mina
just created on the left
so the first thing we'll do is we'll say
quarto preview
and this will open a this will provide a
URL where we can review the previewed
version of the site that Mina has
created so I don't have R installed here
but with the freeze function I'm able to
to open this in this new environment
so here is our beautiful website I like
to kind of have them side by side so I
can see them refresh and if we want to
add a Jupiter notebook let's say oh look
I just added one great let's have a look
at it
so this is a Jupiter notebook I've got
over here on this tab
and this is how we can think about
quarto we've got our yaml at the top
where we're going to say hello to quarto
penguins in Python we've got our
markdown text here and we're going to
use the Palmer Penguins package in
Python this is how we'll it load the
packages
and the way it you operate this in a
Jupiter notebook is that you execute the
code as you go so when I press this play
button this is going to
execute that code and actually embed it
in the document
so we'll do that again with a plot about
penguins
by clicking this button
and now this plot is here as part of the
document
so the workflow here is that you execute
the code as you go and as you develop
and then you save your file as you go so
this is the this is the workflow in in a
jupyter notebook
and when we when we save that now we can
think about adding this to our quarto
yaml and the way we do that is exactly
the way that Mina did before I can add a
Jupiter notebook right here next to
these quarto files
and when we save this yaml file we're
able to peek at the terminal that's
going to tell us when the site refreshes
and there is our indeed our hello quarto
in Python
you can see it's beautiful and it looks
exactly the same as the qmd documents in
our
so let's play around a little bit more
and I'll show you two more things in
um in quarto
so if we wanted to add a figure caption
to this plot we would use the same Hash
Pipe
um comment system that Mina just
introduced
so I can put this figure caption here
and again I can execute and save and
this when I
refresh over here
this will show up in our
sorry in our document and there is our
header are yes our figure caption
but you can see that it's not here it
doesn't do anything to the Jupiter
notebook the it's a comment in the
Jupiter ecosystem this is it's not
affecting the Jupiter notebook at all
let's add one other feature here in the
comment
I'm sorry in the um code chunk option
let's let's say we wanted to display
this plot in the margin Instead This is
a style
that's that's quite popular
so I might have to make this a little
bit wider so we can have a look
a little bit wider okay there is our
plot in the margin uh from a Jupiter
notebook
[Applause]
so let's now say that operating between
formats is really important particularly
when we're in collaborating so if a
workflow that's been really powerful is
to convert Jupiter notebooks into quarto
documents so that uh checking them in
with GitHub can reduce merge conflicts
so what I can do here is to say quarto
convert and tell it the file and it will
by default turn it into a qmd
and you can go back and forth between
these formats so you can see it's
created a new qumd document and when I
open it in the editor here this is now
that same document with our familiar
view and q and d form and you can see
the python code there
so
this has a lot of utility and power and
it's very important for teaching as well
so Mina I'll turn it over to you for
teaching
thank you so over the last decade I have
thoroughly enjoyed teaching with our
markdown when you get students in the
class for the first time and you give
them like a fully functional our
markdown document and ask them to hit
knit and they can see their text and
their code and the output come together
before they even learn any programming
you can almost hear a wow that's so cool
in the classroom and I've also loved
that this tool is something you can
introduce to introductory students on
the first day of class and that it can
grow with them
um however as students expertise grow in
statistics and also in Computing
and also their needs grow in terms of
the different outputs they need to
produce to say just a single homework
document that they can turn in as an
HTML to a well-formatted journal article
or a thesis that meets the school style
there is a little bit of friction that
happens
and one a pleasant surprise for me this
was a pleasant surprise with Corto has
been that this leveling up has been a
lot smoother
um the learning curve for going from a
single document to a multi-document
project has been a lot smoother so I'll
tell the story of one of my students so
this is Holland stem she's an art
history and visual media studies student
who I met when she was taking my
regression course just last spring
Holland came to my class with just one
semester of intradata science under her
belt on where she had learned our
markdown and in my class we dropped
these students into learning Corto after
like a brief overview of how it's
different than our markdown and so she
was you know doing her homework
assignments and stuff as single
documents in our markdown but at the
same time working on her art history
thesis which was pretty quantitative so
if you have ever taken an art history
class you might be familiar with these
two
um textbooks Garner gardeners are
Through the Ages and Jensen's history of
art these are foundational art history
textbooks that have been around for
decades at this point with multiple
editions and what Holland was looking
for is a representation of different
genders and ethnicities of artists and
how much space is given to them in these
textbooks and how this changes over how
it had all this has changed throughout
the editions you can see her
meticulously measuring in this picture
this is exactly what she did to collect
her data actually measure the art that
is featured in the textbooks through the
editions and then join this information
with demographic data on the artists so
that we could analyze and kind of try to
build a model to see if things have
changed over the years what
representation looks like
on the sad side the representation was
exactly what you would imagine the lack
thereof but on the happy side of this
story as she was working on her thesis
she realized each of my chapters could
be just like one of my homework files
because ultimately what do we do in our
homework write a bit of code get some
results out interpret it and that's
exactly what she was doing and then with
a bit of Googling around and a little
bit of help for me she was able to bring
these chapters together with a single
yaml file and you know turned it into
her thesis
um now this wasn't without friction
right um this sort of kind of leveling
up for
um is not easy however when she realized
that she can add captions to her figures
as she creates them in the code chunks
and that she can she does not have to
manually uh style citations millions of
citations she had for this thesis
project that she can just use a visual
Editor to insert these citations she
decided I am willing to put in the
effort to do that
um so as a Side Story Holland was in my
kind of research lab and she also worked
with another student of mine Sarah lemus
and they packaged up this data so Sarah
was incredibly inspired by Holland's
enthusiasm about this project and Sarah
is a stat student who had been working
with me over that semester to
um to learn a little bit of package
development by updating some of the data
packages I maintained so it was very
clear to us that the enthusiasm between
these two students they should come
together and work on this project
together so if you're interested in the
data that Allen collected and Sarah and
Holland put together you can actually
get this package off crime now it's
called art history and has a really cute
hex
um all right so just like Holland
um Corto has solved a lot of my problems
um as an instructor as well so I am
going to uh demo a few of those to you
now first and foremost you can open a
quarter document in the rstudio IDE and
render it now I've shown you this before
why am I saying it again I did not have
to install anything everything comes
bundled so if you are teaching in the
art studio IDE no installation required
and we can basically get going and I
think to me that's incredibly liberating
beyond that though
um there's really handy features for
example with a single yaml field code
link set to true I can each of the
documents that I create can now look a
little bit like package documentation
you may have seen where the functions
are clickable and it takes you directly
to the documentation for that function
and that is incredibly helpful for
Learning and teaching because it saves
me a lot of time from adding those links
now on the learning side let's try to
make a mistake and let's see that it's
really hard I want to write false in
capital letters I'm trying to make a
mistake corta is constantly telling me
don't do it Mina but let's go ahead and
think that I actually managed to do that
and let's render this document the error
that we get is human readable and it
tells me exactly what to do it says
maybe you should try it false in small
letters instead and this is incredibly
helpful for new Learners and also
experts who might be frustrated reading
through cryptic yaml errors it really
kind of pushes you in the right
direction to get things going so that
again you can focus on your content and
not the minutia in a way now as I said
as an educator a lot of slide decks is
kind of like my life so let's turn this
into uh reveal.js presentation again and
let me show you a few of the handy
features here that I use regularly uh
the fact that you get a document Outline
by default is really nice if somebody
loses their place
everyone always asks can I get a PDF of
the slides now they can without you
having to do anything extra
um other things that are really handy is
being able to annotate your slides so we
can turn on the chalkboard feature and
this way you can go to something like a
plot and start outlining things if you
like me have been an educator through
the pandemic I bet you spent hours in
faculty meetings how are we going to
show things to students on Zoom well
this is one way that we can do this we
can also open
a chalkboard and just start writing on
it which is really handy when you're
teaching in a classroom where there's a
projector screen but nothing else I can
also turn on Multiplex which is the
feature we're using right now if you're
following along and it will you know
move forward your slides for you so even
if your students fall asleep they can
sort of you know stay with you as you go
through things in order to do this you
open the speaker file and kind of
present from that and post the
non-speaker file for them
um another thing I'm gonna do here is to
turn on the code so that it is visible
because when I'm teaching I would like
to show the code to my students and
let's show one more handy feature
oftentimes when you have a big chunk of
code like a lengthy GG plot code you may
want to iterate through that
highlighting things line by line so with
one chunk option you can Define which
lines you want to highlight and it
automatically adds animation to your
slides so that you can step through them
and to me that's really helpful because
I didn't have to add characters to my
code to do that now my plot is Tiny
that's not helpful
but again without me having to do extra
work to move it on the next slide I can
say change the output location to next
slide and it will automatically do that
for me without me referring back to a
like an older uh chunk label or
something like that so again a lot of
these things many of you might know how
to solve but I think the fact that
they're solved so elegantly is quite
liberating
um the last thing I'm going to talk
about is what about the research side of
my life well let's open a new project
and let's go ahead and write a paper I'm
going to submit a paper to the Journal
of American statistical association
with one comment I can basically from
the terminal use one of the templates
that are available and there's a growing
number of templates there should I trust
the authors what do you guys think
should we trust the course of
development team I think I'm going to
say yeah okay and I'm going to call this
my awesome paper
um this will generate a template for me
that I can author in quarto which means
I can put my code and my text in the
same document which is how I generally
like to write my
um code and another nice thing here is
that you know if I was to get rejected
from this journal I wanted to submit to
another one changing between Styles is
pretty easy again without changing your
source code
um so let's go ahead and give it a title
my awesome paper that's ready to be
submitted and I'll put my name as first
author and we can render it to a
document and if any of you in the
audience have used the ASA style before
the output should look pretty familiar
to you
oh
now there's unfortunately one drawback
um the corta does not write to your
paper for you
but my experience with the corta
development team is that when you open
issues they're like really quick to
respond so I don't know maybe by the end
of the week they'll figure out how to
write our papers for us too
all right so we've talked about Corto
flattening the learning curve in
um you know basically saying that when
we are leveling up from a single
document to a multi-document input and
going to various output types
um and I said that this was a pleasant
surprise to me in hindsight it should
not have been a surprise it's just not
what I was thinking when I first started
teaching with Corto but if you think
about the features of Corto like
consistent citation syntax across
various formats more intentional control
over when you should run and rerun your
computation
and a single minimal human readable yaml
that controls inputs layouts and theming
everything in one file all of these
features contribute to flattening that
curve for kind of creating more complex
outputs
um but beyond just
um growing and expanding the scope of
your work
um with Corto I think that quarto can
grow with Learners in a profound way as
well
the fact that Cordo is language and uh
independent and also authoring tool
independent offers an opportunity for
folks to take Corto with them in their
data science Journey wherever that
Journey might take them I mean after
working on this for a year almost with
Julie I am almost tempted to Learn
Python and maybe I will
but you know what who is learning python
are my students and they're learning
Python and Julia and other languages
mostly in their computer science courses
and to imagine that they could learn R
in our studio with Corto in my class and
then go take a computer science class
where they're probably living in a
Jupiter notebook and learning python but
still using Porto that sounds like an
incredibly bright future to me
and a bright feature includes things we
can't imagine yet as well
so Julie will now tell us a bit about
reimagining with carto thanks Mina
so we've already seen how much quarto
can do for teaching and collaborating
and sharing
and now I want to push it a bit further
what if we could reimagine open science
as part of the climate movement
we know what this our community and the
open science and open source communities
are capable of
so what if we put that energy towards
climate
because we're in a climate emergency we
must rapidly and radically reshape
Society
we need every solution and every solver
this is hard and it's big and my hope
lies in this community and climate
researchers and everyone in this
movement who feels like what they do
every single day plays A Part
so let's think about this concretely
with three user groups in this community
of in this movement
first our scientists who are working
directly in line with climate change
this could be Fisheries scientists who
are studying where our food sources are
migrating to is the ocean's warm and
operating with managers and stakeholders
they're so they're working with really
hard problems these really hard big
problems and they can also feel stuck on
the little problems of moving files
around and interoperating with each
other
that's really where openscapes has been
really bringing this passion and this
movement that we feel in the our
community to help these researchers and
help connect to them there
and I think now so many of you that I
talked to in the open source and our
communities in this okay so the second
category is
open science and our communities
I know a lot of you are feeling stuck
too you're feeling the the pressure on
climate and feeling like changing to
more efficient light bulbs isn't enough
what if you aligned your daily work as
part of climate action as well
we want posit to be around in a hundred
years what is a hundred years going to
look like if we don't act now and really
put this effort together
and the third category in theme with the
conference is extensible extendable
Beyond these two categories
so we really need every solution and
every solver across all facets of
geographies and people and skill level
and experience with technology
so this work is really hard and we'll
we'll return to concrete things that we
can do in a moment but this really does
mean slowing down a bit in order to
speed up
it's but it speeds up like a flywheel
my colleague Ileana Fenwick is a marine
ecologist who participated in openscapes
earlier last year and she really quickly
became a member of the team teaching and
extending and connecting other
communities and seeing what was possible
and the way she describes this is
beautiful
because of openscapes I've renewed hope
and how we can bring about a Kinder
future in science I see a commitment in
the open science Community to Bridging
the gaps where we've left members of our
own of our community behind and it
inspires me
so we're talking about a profound
culture shift that involves real
deliberate work on both the tech and The
Human Side
and we've got the tech side really
figured out it's we're the momentum and
the potential and what we're all doing
is amazing and phenomenal
and we can bring that power and energy
to The Human Side too we can build
inclusion into our daily work
so let's think about the teams or the
colleagues or the people that you
interact with because I think that they
are probably way more similar to the
groups I work with than we might expect
first of all it means talking to
colleagues asking them how they're doing
are they stuck what does their workflow
look like
where is their friction who's
contributing to our workflow where are
the handoffs maybe between reports or
data where are people feeling friction
what can we do to help
so this means asking all these questions
but really and that's hard enough those
open-ended questions
the another hard part is listening
listening is really hard
it takes it means that you are not
trying to assume what they need you're
not trying to solution here as soon as
you hear something because oftentimes we
don't even have language to describe
where we're stuck and that's part of the
problem
so it also means then stepping up and
being braver to ask for help and say
what you need and really create this
culture where what we feel in the art
community around our code is also
applicable to climate
so this is a practice to develop daily
to work on to help others with it's not
a checklist it's a daily thing that we
can all do
so here's a practical example of this
Gavin phase lab group at UMass Dartmouth
created the failab manual together
during the pandemic
here they so they are quantitative
Fisheries ecologists they work with data
and code to to work on Fisheries
things that I just described a bit
earlier
so
it is uncommon for
people in the environmental field to
have data science training in the
universities right now so that means
people coming into this quantitative
group have varying levels of expertise
and experience
and so they wrote this lab manual as a
way to not only write down their lab
philosophy their code of conduct how
they wanted to work together they talked
about where how to name files and also
how to learn the tools that they're
going to develop together
so this is a living online Open document
and it's imperfect
and it's radical in science where we
often wait until after the research is
done to publish something and that
happens years into a career and really
limits the participation folks feel they
have an agency they have
so this is radical in three ways or in
many ways but let me tell you three of
them one is that it makes the implicit
explicit the team all know because they
co-created the document they're all on
the same page literally cuarto page
um and to understand how they work
together they're able to put their
values forward and not only reduce the
amount of emails where people are asking
where things are but also really put
this out there and welcome other people
to join them and when folks are
interested in joining this lab group
they mention this document as a
welcoming reason
a second thing is that this document on
boards Learners as contributors so first
of all there is an onboarding process
and it's written in the in the in the
site
and so it instructs you not only to how
the lab works but also how you can use
quarto to fix a typo to update a link
you saw so you're contributing to the
lab group you're you're joining in that
way and you're in being you're
contributing to science on day one and
that is just amazing to have that kind
of empowerment and imagine where what
you feel like you're gonna do in science
next
so this is hugely radical for science
and a third most radical thing is the
the investment they put into
psychological safety and growth mindsets
in their group
psychological safety is the idea that
it's a shared understanding within a
team that that team is safe for
interpersonal risk taking that means
that people are feel comfortable to ask
a question if they don't know something
that they feel like they can give and
receive feedback
so this is really important along with a
growth mindset where everyone can learn
from everyone this is the power of yet
I don't know this yet I don't I can't do
this yet but I can and that kind of
mindset and learning across
the hierarchy of science across
expertise and skills thinking that we
all have something to contribute is
really important
So reimagining within this one lab group
then can scale that this slowing down
can then have rapid effects with that
speeding up and amplifying so really
quickly after this we forked the Fey
Labs idea and wrote Our Own quarto
approach guide for openscapes
together and on board ourselves and
onboard others to the team and also
other groups are able to use it too the
California water boards are leading
their first openscape sessions this
summer
and at NOAA Fisheries they saw what NASA
was doing and forked that idea with
quarto so they are using quarto for a
place to build a community across their
NOAA science centers for open science
and to connect and to empower and enable
these early adopters within each of
these silos
so these are examples of quarto for
culture change and it's amazing we can
do this with the same tooling that we're
using for our reproducible research at
the same time these documents from where
they are now have don't have any code in
them they're they're and Corso is a
really friendly place for folks to
contribute no matter where their comfort
level is with code
and that's really important we've
already seen features of quarto that are
really friendly and with guard rails to
help new Learners contribute
and another way for this for newcomers
to contribute is in the visual editor
and I so I'm going to do one final demo
here about the visual editor but I also
want to emphasize that while I'm well
we're going to look at it through the
lens of a new user this is a really
powerful tool for experienced users and
so as as part of this mindset of helping
welcome other people as I walk through
this maybe consider how you might use
this approach to welcome one of your
colleagues who might be
um less less sure about this kind of
tech
so here's here we are in the IDE and
I've opened Mina's homepage I her
homepage quarter document and I'm
immediately going to go to the visual
editor like she showed before
so I can I can type in quarto
um in the visual editor and then I can
use the menu bars up here as I would in
a Google doc to make a header
and as I type I can also
highlight words and make them italic I
can use keyboard shortcuts like command
I to turn off the italics
and this is a way that I can comfortably
write my text I can also paste forward
matted text this is a way we use quarto
quite often is by interoperating between
other documents that we're using and
it's amazing that it saves that
formatting
if we want to add an image
we can use the insert feature here
and see all of these different things
that we'd be able to insert right now
we'll insert an image and we could type
this or browse a file
I'll speed this up for the purpose of
our demo in a moment we can set Center
but I'm going to paste the caption and
the alt text for us right now and then
we can press ok
and this is now in the visual editor we
can see it we can understand how it
interoperates with our document
and we can also resize it there on the
Fly which is awesome
if we're interested in the source code
let's have a look at it
and you can see down here on line 15 is
where the image is and that where the
cursor is we've got the width and the
figure line Center that's what we had
done with our Mouse but that's now in
quarto for us
so back in the visual editor
let's save this and click that render on
save button that will then let us see
this live rendered output alongside the
visual editor so I love that render on
save button when I don't have a lot of
heavy computation so that I can every
time I save I get to see exactly how it
looks beautiful over here
okay we can fix this typo with those
nice red squiggle lines and let's add a
citation let's add a citation for the
Tidy verse we can do this with a command
a or sorry a at symbol
and pull up my zotero library that's all
right that it's found on my computer I
can type
sorry okay
I can type either Wickham or tidy or I'm
sure many other things
and what and when I add when I save
again it's there already in the document
and I've got the references down here
this is amazing
a second way you can do it is to use the
forward slash and click citation
and then you're able to
actually even paste a DOI on the Fly and
it will find it for you
yes
[Applause]
you can see when I take when I save this
it's in a different
style which is great that you have that
kind of control right here from the
browser
or from the visual editor I'm sorry
I have a few more features to show here
but I'm thinking in the interest of time
we'll let you watch this online by
yourself later
so I want to bring this back as we close
our our keynote and just say again that
we are all part of this we've been
talking about what quarto enables
throughout this talk but this is about
what we are able to reimagine at all
levels we can all play our part to do
this in our daily work and with our
teams and scale and Beyond so we invite
you to reimagine with us because we
cannot we must not go It Alone
so if you would like to pick up uh your
Corto journey to share collaborate
teacher reimagine where we left off go
to this link for our slides and you're
going to see that we have a few more
slides for you with resources to learn
Porto and also
um references to some of the works that
we've cited and there's a quarto session
later on this afternoon at 3 20 and the
Corto and our markdown teams will be at
the open source Lounge between 12 and 3
today thank you so much for joining us
this morning
[Applause]
okay
[Music]